[inaudible]
we've gone through the basics of
morphemes and covered a few word classes.
Now we move on to a part of
speech known as the adjective.
You're probably aware that
adjectives describe nouns,
but you might not have considered
their function from a morphological
perspective.
Sometimes they work more like nouns
and sometimes they're more like verbs.
Let's start with some examples.
In ancient Greek adjectives declined
exactly like nouns do. In fact,
they routinely take the same
endings for number, gender and case.
Since that's true, we
can see examples like
[inaudible] the just person or the
fair person versus [inaudible],
which would mean the just
woman or the fair woman.
And in that case we have an opposition
between decos which is masculine,
singular and nominative as well.
And [inaudible], which is feminine,
singular and nominated.
In both situations we have an
adjective describing a noun,
but they're working like a
now declining like a noun.
Now I'll draw a counter example
from Japanese. In Japanese,
many adjectives work a lot
more like verbs. In fact,
they're specifically what we
would call state of verbs,
which are verbs that indicate
a state instead of an action.
So a description like is happy
or is hot would indicate a state,
for example, a to means
is hot in Japanese.
Those can act as true
adjectives in front of a now.
Or they can instead take the place of a
verb in languages that treat adjectives
more like nouns. Don't be surprised
to find them used as a noun.
Take the ancient Greek example
I gave you just a moment ago.
I can instead say [inaudible],
which means literally the just or the
fare in English that would translate to
the just one or the fair
one. And in that case,
we have decos working exactly like what
we would expect the noun to work like in
Greek. On the other hand, in Japanese,
the words I used in those sentences
work exactly as we would expect,
a verb to work and they're
conjugated like a Japanese Ferb.
There's a good deal more to be said
for adjectives beyond these basics,
but it's worth reviewing the lessons
on nouns and verbs to dig into their
properties and come around next time when
we meet the very versatile grammatical
particle
[inaudible].